[Music]
the graboids are giant Subterranean
wormlike monsters that were introduced
in the movie Tremors from way back in
the 1990s and its subsequent sequels
these are ancient underground monsters
that have been stated to have existed
from the Precambrian age and survived
the hundreds of millions of years
underground they have a weird body
structure and even weird the anatomy and
a very interesting life cycle so in
short the main graboid is around 20 to
30 ft long and weighs an excess of 20
tons its body's shape is similar to a
slug but with spikes around its body
that it uses to dig and Traverse Ong
ground its life cycle is separated into
different stages which includes the X an
underground phase a terrestrial phase
and also an aerial one but here in this
video we will skip all that and go
straight to the four different species
that they have evolved into and was seen
in the many movies and series we will
describe them and their life stages and
then make a comparison as well so let's
get to it the first species the American
graboid seen in the first four Tremor
movies this is the first species to be
discovered and they were found in
Perfection Valley in Nevada USA when
fully grown into its graboid Stage IT
measures 30 ft or 9 M long with three
snake likee tongues that emerge from the
central mouth and stretch out for
another 3 m or 10 ft the three tongues
each have a mouth teeth and two pairs of
horn-like projections on the upper jaw
and also they have a lower jaw they also
seem to work semi-independently like the
Arms of an octopus and are equipped with
touch sensory organs the grab's body is
encased in a height that is thick and
leathery with rough Pebble texture
giving it a reptile-like appearance but
studies suggest that these are more
related to cuttlefish than any other
life form the central mouth of the
graboid is composed of an armored beak
with a lower jaw and an upper jaw and
also two manales from the side
so the life cycle of this graboid starts
with an egg that can lay Domin for
centuries on end and then when suitable
factors kick in they hatch and a small
dirt Dragon stage comes out which then
grows into maturity in a matter of 3
months the mature graboid then dies and
from inside of its body emerge three
shers which have the same graboid mouth
but with legs to move on the surface
these shers emit a high frequency sound
and possess a thermal imaging organ on
their heads after a few days of
asexually reprodu producing and growing
in number they then shed into the last
stage which is called the ass Blaster
that has wings and can glide in the air
their name as it suggests tells us that
these creatures emit a highly flamable
gas from their butts which ignites and
propels them into the air then these ass
blasts lay the next set of eggs in Hot
Springs and the cycle continues the next
species is the African graboid this
species was seen in the movie Tremors
five Bloodlines and they are a bit
different than their American species
counterparts other than having a more
robust body and a stronger exoskeleton
their mouth also differ slightly as
their lower jaw has split into two parts
giving them the appearance of a mouth
with five individual beaks they can also
jump into the air from under the ground
and Ambush their prey with smarter
tactics they have far more prominent
body spines skeletal looking ridges on
their bodies and they are bigger than
their American cousins with them
measuring 40 to 50 ft long or 12 to 15 M
their most prominent difference though
is their tongue likee tentacles which
can detach and function as independent
organisms they also appear to look like
face huggers from the alien franchise
rather than snakes hence getting the
name Grabbers so their life cycle is
pretty much similar even though we did
not see any form of shrier in the area
where they were propagating so it's
probably the same eggs dirt dragons
graboids then shers and the ass blasters
the last stage the aerial form differs
greatly from the American counterparts
while the American ass blasters are are
elegant in shape and have a gliding wing
with a long beak like mouth the African
ass blasters have a rounder body with
flappable wings and a mouth that is
circular with shock-like teeth other
differences include them being faster
and stronger also having a more powerful
as blast as well as being nocturnal
Hunters rather than day Hunters as in
the case of the Americans the African
species as blasters also lay their eggs
inside of caves instead of hot springs
the third species the Arctic graboid
seen in the movie Tremors a cold day in
Hell these are the third species to be
discovered however the movie suggests
that this species might have been the
Primal genitor the first one and then
they gradually evolve into the other
species as they propagated and went
South in appearance they have the
rougher body design of the African
variant but smaller in size measuring 10
m or 33 ft long and weighing 20 tons
just like the American species they have
a five-way potting mouth and a set of
three Grabbers that cannot detach from
from their main body like the American
but possesses the appearance of the
African species Grabbers they also
follow a similar life cycle as the
African species with no shrier stage
seen and the as Blaster stage closely
resembles the African ones which tells
us that the Arctic species may be more
closely related to the African ones than
the American species although the
Americans are closer by location they
however lay eggs in Hot Springs and also
got their brute of eggs unlike the
Perfection Valley species now lastly the
fourth species is the oceanic graboid
which is a Genetically Enhanced species
that was brought into southeast Asia by
a hunter and then propagate them in game
Island this species was seen in Tremor
shria Island the movie and measures 30
ft or 9 M long like the American species
but looks like a mix between both
American and African species it has the
African species mouth which parts five
ways but the body of an American species
the tongues are similar to the Arctic
species
but it has one trait which is unique
from all the others this species can
swim from one Island to the other it is
also more powerful end durable than the
others with it having the ability to
pierce through or penetrate the thick
bunker walls which were built to endure
nuclear blasts anyway its life cycle is
also pretty much the same and it is the
only other variant that has the Sha form
although its shria stage has segmented
bony armors on their heads and can emit
a shriek that paralyzes victims or prey
items hence weaponizing their sound they
will also develop into the ass blasters
but they were killed off before they got
the chance so with that we come to the
end of this graboid video and the four
different species now if you like this
video then watch this other one as well
and do check out our channel for other
monster content we might have things you
haven't seen before like subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video take
care fam